of course the health crisis has provoked
the financial crisis Wall Street ended
the trading week with another steep
sell-off on Friday at the close the Dow
lost more than 900 points the S&P 500
and Nasdaq also fell sharply that helped
make last week the worst in US markets
since 2008 with a doubt losing 17% of
its value and that's just some of the
economic fallout we are seeing right now
including massive layoffs and
predictions of an unprecedented slowdown
CBS News senior business analyst just
less enger' is here to tell us more
about what we're facing and how you
should handle it Jill good morning good
morning
alright so the bear market is now down
30% which is about typical for a bear
market right now but obviously a crazy
week on Wall Street Jill do you feel
like things have settled down at all I
don't think so not yet and I think that
we're about to see a lot more volatility
here's what's going on if you're a
trader and you're seeking guidance about
what's happening in the economy you're a
bit flying blind and until we get more
data these are sort of guesstimates so
let me tell you what economists are
telling me they're looking at a
recession that is probably already
started when the end and remaining in
the middle of this quarter that we're in
the first quarter but if you look at the
second quarter of this year we're
looking at analysts who are saying we
could have a drop of 25% that's what
Goldman Sachs says 14% JPMorgan Chase to
put those numbers in perspective we
haven't seen quarterly drops like that
since the Great Depression
we are worst quarter in 2008 was the
last quarter and that was down eight
point nine percent so the economic
uncertainty is breeding the sell-off and
until there's more certainty I don't
think that's gonna stop anytime soon
some of the staggering numbers that
we've seen with the economy screeching
to a halt I believe was how you had put
it is the impact on jobs right now and
some record numbers and losses
I think the job loss numbers we are
going to see a lot more coming up so we
have one data point that was released on
Thursday that's weekly jobless claims
and they spiked by 33% from the previous
week when we get the next week's results
which will be next
we are likely to see a million maybe two
million job jobless claims applications
now when people are looking at the
unemployment rate overall remember we
came into this period at a 50-year low
of three and a half percent it's likely
to spike up to six to eight percent
which is pretty hefty and and I know
it's agonizing for those who are losing
their jobs it may be more than that but
the good news is that most of the
economists who have very dark
predictions for the first half of the
year they do believe that sometime in
the middle of the summer the economy
will pick up and those folks will go
back to work in part in Park Jill
because banks are structurally in a
better place than they were twelve years
ago now in 2008 the government spent
seven hundred billion dollars in a
bailout what what about that worked and
didn't it and what do you think the
government should be using this one
trillion dollars plus for right now to
help people today and next month the
government has two different responses
we have the Federal Reserve that's
pulled out the break the glass playbook
from 2008 and 2009 so the Federal
Reserve all the actions that they are
taking are simply to make sure that the
nation's financial plumbing remains
unclogged very important with this
trillion dollar plan we have got to see
money go directly to people who are
harmed there's talk of maybe one to
three thousand dollars of checks to
families based on the size of the family
this would be about a five hundred
billion dollars but we're talking about
keeping other businesses alive as well
so we want to give direct relief to the
people but we want them to be able to
return to a job so fifty billion dollars
for the airline industry a hundred fifty
billion dollars to other impacted
sectors and three hundred billion
dollars to small business you know how
helping people individually didn't help
that that didn't happen twelve years ago
right we help the banks we help car
companies we didn't help people
individually yeah we had a plan
to help people modify their mortgages
but we did not do enough and the plan
was really laden with so much red tape
we need money in the hands of people I
interviewed a Nobel Prize winning
economist this week he believes that
whatever we do must
continue so it can't be a one-time
thousand-dollar check he says money
needs to get to people to help them
survive during these times and we have
to get businesses able to withstand this
this is a critical all right Jill
Schlesinger thank you